if you've been craving IRL Pokemon since
you first laid eyes on a Bulbasaur then
you might not have to wait that much
longer I'm Lucy and this is your
augmented reality powered gamespot news
updates what appears to be the first
footage of my antics hotly anticipated
Pokemon go mobile game has been revealed
the footage was reportedly shot at 96
CEO John hankies presentation this
weekend at South by Southwest we don't
see Hankey in the video but it
definitely sounds like him in the video
Hankey talks about the ambitious game
which challenges players to track out
into the real world in search of Pokemon
and then capture them just like in the
main games the video has already racked
up over 1 million views you'll also be
able to play the game with an optional
device called Pokemon go plus much like
a smart watch it can be worn on the
wrist and used to execute in-game
actions such as catching a Pokemon the
device will connect to smartphones using
bluetooth and will flash its LED and
vibrate to notify players about nearby
pokemon pokemon go which enters its
field test phase this month in Japan
lets players catch train and battle
monsters in the real world and the video
from South by Southwest shed some light
on how this works the game is expected
to be available on the App Store and
Google Play in 2016 as a free download
but will also have in-app purchases
there's a game look as good as you'd
like it to or are you furious that hanky
used a master ball on an IV saw let me
know in the comments or you can find me
on Twitter at Lucy James games thanks
for watching and for all your pokemon
news reviews and updates make sure you
keep it gamespot com
you